Yeah.
Nice.
Tones, we need them.
Okay.
Is that still Romario?
Hold on, all good, then, I think.
Ah, okay, good, great.
Yeah, now he can hear, now it's good.
And, well, pretty much
everyone's here now.
I'd just get started, as I said,
it's also been announced, so,
if you've missed anything you can go back
and watch the recording afterwards.
I think Nikola is still missing,
but I'll start now — maybe iPhone.
Right, I'll just carry on,
let's keep going.
I've only got limited time,
I'd like to push on.
And I'm just doing
the overview.
Yeah, for me too,
you can even,
if there's precipitation,
that gets shown too.
So,
that's enough, actually it has all the
info
you need,
as a normal pilot.
And also,
also, also,
of course,
and down below,
with the outlook further ahead.
So,
I think,
I've also got another tool,
where you can go further out, and another tool
where you can go out a bit further and yet another one.
And actually, as we did at the beginning,
always with an emagram alongside,
the two-week reference,
you've got, say, cloud formation,
independent of the thermal development.
Actually very, very nicely
visible.
That's basically everything for Meteo-Parapro.
Then,
I use,
actually
not extremely much.
There are just a few things
with Burnair
that I find quite good.
There are also a few things
where I think,
a bit,
yeah, useful,
or not,
where what we do,
and my own preferences,
a bit,
the wealth of information,
I think,
makes it, makes it a bit
cluttered,
but
it's already
quite cool
what it
offers.
And there's also a few options
for which map you want to open.
Burnair,
their map,
there you've got the launch sites and so on
to read out,
also done very well,
and you can read out valley winds,
it always depends
on what you've unlocked,
what's enabled
or not.
What you could,
select there,
if we now just go to the
wind forecast,
which works well for us,
then,
yeah, we'll just go straight to it,
yeah,
but we're also a bit
cluttered,
yeah,
then
the choice,
the selection,
with which we can choose.
So, if clouds
and precipitation
right at the beginning
the good thing,
look a bit cluttered
the way it's set up,
the way it appears now,
then you could just
switch them off top left,
and then that's already out of the way.
And then on the left you've got
the altitudes for the respective
winds
with over 200,
500 metres above ground,
which I don't find too bad.
Yeah,
I've got the altitudes
you can play through,
with what's down at the bottom,
age,
with that,
because I actually
find the latter,
where you can
look a bit further into the future.
and there it has,
and this is really quite
important,
there quite
a lot of options to
fade out.
We can
various,
various backgrounds
choose.
So, you can,
for you,
and that's where it's always about what you could keep going with. But what I find
cool now, you can see the things I've got faded in, the live pressure values,
you always have to look for yourself, where it is, MeteoSwiss live, the changes,
those are things I've already got faded in here, live wind values you can
fade in. You can set quite a lot, which can also be done, but then it gets a bit
cluttered too — but if there's lots of notifications, when you've got lots set, all the
ones turned off and then pull in only what you want, what you need. There too I think it's really cool,
when you initially zoom out a bit and look at it from further out,
where there are really regions with very, very strong wind, and where you're perhaps just sheltered,
you can also play through the various altitudes there, we're here just at
1,500 and 2,000 metres, then you can see really well, it's now very good, always with wind
it's very good, but here maybe even a bit better, also more clearly
displayed for me, with the colours triggered again, at altitudes it's even more recognisable, so you have to
give it to Burnair, with that, very well done, you can really pick out very nicely, especially with
Foehn situations, also at 2,000 metres it becomes more apparent, and I think,
I have to say also from the presentation it's very good, so you have to leave it at that,
they've done that very well, if you now want to look a bit more in detail,
the preview items also get shown, when I click on it, it opens down there,
where I have to honestly admit, I find it a bit cluttered, so
it's not quite so easy to read out, where there's maybe a more stable stratification
in there, so you can read it out well, but I just find from the visual presentation,
I find that Meteo-Parapro has solved that better, but here too you can see in the
intense altitudes set, with the small breeze and the table down there or
the mean value for the respective altitude, you've also got the bathing altitude with it there,
actually here too a lot of information, can up top, when the cloud
amount or rather which level they're set at, how you see that,
when a bit of precipitation builds up, but also there you can really pull a lot of
stuff out, what I find very good in all of this, we're here with
the temperature very quickly, like the wind intensity at altitude — for example, we were in 2023 down in
Ticino, it really was bloody cold, at 2,200, 2,000 metres it really had minus 8,
minus 10 degrees, at 2,000 something walls then I think already minus 5, 10 degrees and we could
read that out there, and then you really froze very quickly in the air,
so you can see here minus 0.1 degrees temperature, so it's very cold, right? And
wind intensity marked in red, so we're already quite good there, I just find
simply that the wealth of information makes it a bit cluttered for me,
but in itself you can also read out a lot.
From my knowledge only with a paid subscription, as I said for you actually the Windisk and also
here you could really, with the wind, fly in the various altitudes, because I just find only
what's cool here are live high-fog limits for the north and south and Foehn a bit better laid out,
that means for seven also a bit more in that direction, so there's already a decent amount of
information available there and with that you can also prepare well.
A general forecast, we have to see, I'd use a maximum of three such apps and then
try to figure out which one for you, ahead of that, is the most reliable, and then
you'll see very quickly what you can work well with, with which one for your purposes.
As I said, you have the option to fade in precipitation and clouds, and simply
trafficked, it shows the clouds, we move across the terrain, this here is all covered in clouds,
this is again very, very well done, and the precipitation zones logically
get highlighted here with blue-green, so here you've got proper precipitation, and you can also
read out cloud amount, cloud height even, and the precipitation, those I think are actually
well done. As I said, you can check, with Burnair, there are yearly explanations,
you can read extremely much out with their app. I'd also, let me say,
reduce it to a minimum for you, because here too I've made the experience that the
forecast, it does take the ICON model, but I find the forecast tends to be clearly
pessimistic, on the more pessimistic side, so working only with Burnair means for me
really clearly fewer launches, which isn't fundamentally wrong, but if you
know that, then you can perhaps add another source on top, and then you've
perhaps got clearly more flying days, so if you only prepare with Burnair,
in my view it's a bit too pessimistic, but good information overall I find extremely
important and good. Whoever has a paid subscription, you can, I'll put it in the T3 later for you,
you can save 10 francs there with a voucher code from me, on the respective subscription, and
save yourselves a bit there fundamentally, but also here, click in, dig in
really very well, possible, and shows really, where there's more wind,
where there might be areas with less wind, where I could rather go fly, and what's very, very nicely
presented here, you can really see very quickly at 1,500 and 2,000 metres Foehn, and makes
it really nicely visible, and I find that especially for today and respectively tomorrow
and the days, yeah, with the altitudes chosen, yeah, I find it very good and it works
and that's my experience, I find it very successful in terms of the presentation. Right, that's wind,
clouds, precipitation, with these 3 apps you can actually work through it very well,
you should always also take the ground into account, you've got that with me on the app anyway, there you've
got the measurement and the forecast from MeteoSwiss overlaid, which is
very good, but for those who want to look a bit further ahead. We've seen,
you can do isobars with Windy, but from the German Weather Service there are also these forecast charts
and under MeteoSwiss they're also produced, but there on the site itself, you've got the option
to also look somehow into the future and you still don't only have isobars,
but also the corresponding fronts. It's actually for me for my preparation
important, there I can really look up to 100 hours into the future and immediately see
whether we're under high pressure influence or closer to low pressure influence, then keep going to Saturday.
Saturday is then a transition day, Sunday I think doesn't look so bad, but
pretty much the whole region, exactly, you can actually look at what's hitting in the corners,
which also showed up in the analysis, it's always fully under high pressure influence, there was a
so-called pressure sector, between the individual systems we're stuck there as it were and that
I actually find a very cool way to look clearly further into the future,
as far as the surface pressure distribution and the large-scale weather pattern go. There it is at the
German Weather Service, on the link, and the instructions and analysis and forecast page. I can
send you the link directly in the chat, simply because we want to drop in there, so they're
actually quite cool and it's a very good preparation. As I said, the analysis,
like the forecast calculation from MeteoSwiss, which by now everybody has on their phone,
MeteoSwiss with the forecast calculation, surface pressure chart, now for 13:00 local,
then we can very nicely compare them with each other, that belongs for me actually also to the preparation
as well. For those of you who are signed up with me, also a meteo section, which also offers a lot of
information, among other things yet another wind program, so that one has
in particular a different calibration, by day, even a bit better, visible,
whether you can still fly with it or not. What I don't find quite so good,
is simply the limit at 5 Beaufort, it has often shown here that 4 actually from 4,
it really became noticeably stronger, and that's why I think 4 is still
a limit you shouldn't go over, from my point of view, that's why I find the limit at 5 Beaufort
not quite so well chosen, but what is a bit better there, it doesn't quite feel right down there,
and there at the top we have to be already a bit closer to reality, and I'd
say it's really good, I have there, or there's an example of these weather services, which also have
various diagrams, yeah, in the left area also still precipitation, you've got clouds,
which you can call up. And what's quite cool there, I think, but you can call up tower data, if you
click on it briefly. No, that's not what I wanted, when you do that on the
preview, yeah, on the page that's possible, so you can call them up and then you've got, and there
I've got precipitation, I've got such a fine tower, you can also call up the so-called 5 Beaufort,
also very, very nicely, then go through to tomorrow, how you've got it as the 5th window,
what then gets broken down towards evening, so for example also something we can use very, very well
in the preview. Yeah, I'm set up there the same way, just switched to yellow now, no longer the
COSMO, COSMO model, but the ICON model, from that, you have to look now, the
forecasts are certainly a bit more accurate again, cloud amount, precipitation, that hasn't quite so
how the western front comes in, so I don't find it so bad, then it starts up
there, there are already certain offshoots, it's definitely the case there, so it's also not
so bad for preparation, but you also use the weather service, there we have various
many diagrams, not just the so-called wind diagrams, I find those tedious there, you've got
events ahead there, because they offer austen-thermo more richly, sure, we had it like that for you, there was also
wind and Garda very, worked very well, then something against clouds used, which worked excellently
for us, was the Bora diagram, that also helped me very well down there, I find
it very good and there's three for France, you can really choose between various diagrams
and I find that excellent for flight preparation, you can really at a
glance see why something happens, when we're now at our place, when there's a sharp pressure drop
present here, that means, the front comes in somewhere there, and that too is for the
weather preparation very, very important, I think that was also pulled up in the app for me. Right, what
maybe also as an additional point, precipitation and cloud amount or cloud radar, I look at that
quite a lot on MeteoSwiss on the app on the phone, that works quite well, also
there there are forecasts here and now that don't come in, but precipitation forecast, I find
quite very good there and belongs for me to the whole day always inside, but I think
most can do that with the app on the phone, so you should definitely include that in
your forecast. Right, then I'd quickly go through a wind forecast with you,
and a cloud forecast with the various respectively only quickly with Burnair, Meteo,
Parapro and Windy and Autark, then there's the so-called cloud-cover tab, but that's on the
phone better visible. Right, then I'd quickly with Windy go through the data for tomorrow's day,
but yeah, we don't have to look that far into the future, for tomorrow's day, if I now go here on
the ICON-D2, we see alone, without me looking at altitude, but from the European one, actually
two to the DWD, German Weather Service, we have Biber and of course also once a whole different
wind speed, but 34, that's after all 11 km/h, and there we have to then the respective
altitudes, at the moment I really recommend you look closely at the 3,000 wind, well down
come, punching through, we don't yet have such a thermal cushion that the whole thing
can absorb very well, or better said, pushes very well up away and that's why always the 3,000
wind definitely include, maybe I'll even start a bit higher up first,
4,000 wind goes once again a bit out, and only afterwards back into the depth, so there we now have
presumably, at 4,000 km/h wind forecast, and 12 o'clock, we now do the lift-off the day, because only around
midday and then it would be important that you also look in the morning, what is around midday really
of wind present, we have certain measuring stations also at 3,000 metres in our area
you can call up and see whether that's really, then we go back down there, go there
again to 3,000 rounds, the crowning, 2,000, 3,000, as I said, 45 km/h, you see that we down there
have considerably less wind, 27 situations, but easy to fly off, with filling also
leeward, you could maybe fly, if there's no precipitation, if the wind anyway
isn't too strong, but yeah, with that much at one go down there it still has stowed precipitation and
that's not so good, exactly, that means, so, and if we now have a bit of a round
at the 3,000 wind right now not so good, but let's go below that and have
a km/h in the nest, where you can really also down and a km/h see, it could roughly
be what.
I've got it in the lower compartments.
I'm just drilling in with the priest,
so we have it after 2:00 in the morning.
There we launch many.
There you have to see the broadcast right away at home,
not only under the area,
but it doesn't start for us,
the trees don't go away,
not here either.
For the o'clock at 2,000 metres the broadcast
was unanimous.
The hand-word, the hand-word out and the hand in km/h, wind, south-westerly direction and then
we actually deflect there clock, the strong, then we can call it.
Right, okay, fundamentally one is, okay, gusty wind picks up, I'll just go down a bit
more, with Windy, er, with Meteo-Parapro, than with Windy.
Then let's look what, as I said, Burnair, so the meteorological side,
and then so, you plan further with the SchlavenAut, so on one of those Meteo-Parapro,
and then there's one tacked on, extra tacked on, km/h, wind on, so in itself unanimous,
that means again that it's pretty sure to occur, or more, how can you see
the hit rate, that it'll also fit, 1pm, so same theme,
then also the theme, the at 3:30, the theme too, definitely stronger.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And if you don't really feel it anymore, if you bring the whole thing along right away,
then you've got the first one, the one with the diagram, always that one there, for me exactly,
there the emagram still, yeah, towards Friday, also with the evening, if you look at it with the weather lady
you look at, then you don't have any more there, but you see that there,
the whole morning, feels after the day, sets in,
since up there, where can you bring that in, towards attention,
and there finally in, the whole time, knowing that,
maybe also built up like that, all three side by side,
you can prepare yourself very very well for the respective day,
the rough forecast becomes, I, well, also still a text forecast take with three,
so with the Swiss text forecast reading, I find already attention,
again with one with loading, yeah, visible, maybe Foehn comes up,
or it's every-other weather, low pressure determined, with precipitation,
fronts, I'm often in the weather report integrated, in the text forecast,
that's why it's I think still important, that that also gets included.
Weather, it's like that too, you should look, you can use up a lot of time there,
or need, that's why, you always have to look, when you're already going up,
you pull yourself together, yeah, but Friday, Saturday it's solitary,
then I'd say, too much in detail make my forecast,
when I see something, and then I can look at Sunday more precisely again,
and that of course always on Saturday, on Saturday, so on Saturday,
leave, Sunday focus on, get those that come,
that can also be that the low-pressure with traction and pressure is a long-stretching river-leak occlusion.
Of course, for your own planning already,
we have to be clearly better, you can about it,
there's the traction patches, but it's still not far,
because I think, that won't really be expected either,
because we don't yet have more.
That's not yet so much.
But with you you can't go in there into Friday,
into the model, into Friday, into the model.
I'd sometimes leave it standing,
when I've actually from my side so far gotten an overview,
so once for wind, then I'd quickly stub up the whole thing here,
and afterwards, whoever's keen, look at clouds and precipitation,
on the grave it's offline since yesterday.
Yeah, from Burnair you also can't see it,
we'd have it for some reason.
Yeah, the lows there have actually broken off from the launch wind,
notarised or on the other technical background.
But I can't actually say at the moment.
Okay.
So, you're in the school then.
And you exactly here in the school.
And you recognise that.
And you yourself, you do a band here.
And you've passed the albums into the (unclear).
And to be, there is a new speech.
You're back in the school.
And she's gone into the school.
...
Here it's been found in the school with the hand.
You observe being on your way, and I can the hip,
Okay, good, then we've got one minute left now.
Every moment needs to convert.
And then once again open a new session with clouds
and precipitation.
And then I'd say,
at the end still answer further questions.
Then we've got it down.
Okay, good.